I first became acquainted with the
Amazon jungle
halfway through 1958 thanks to my friend
Rosita corps poncho her function at the
University of San Marcos was the hague
her power unlimited sheep rolled among
the professors without being one of them
and they all did whatever she asked
thanks to her wild doors of officialdom
stock shops were open and pats of
bureaucracy smooth yet there is a place
available for someone on an expedition
to the alto marin young that's been
organized by the institute of
linguistics for a mexican anthropologist
she said to me one day when I ran into
her on the campus of the Faculty of
letters would you like to go I had
finally managed to obtain the fellowship
to Europe I had coveted and was to leave
for Spain the following month but I
accepted without a moment's hesitation
Rosita is from Loreto and if you listen
carefully you can still catch in her
voice an echo of the delightful singsong
accent of Eastern Peru she protected and
promoted as no doubt she still does the
Summer Institute of linguistics an
organization which in the forty years of
its existence in Peru has been the
object of violent controversy I
understand that as I write these lines
it is packing its bags to leave the
country not because it has been expelled
though this was on the verge of
happening during general Velasco
dictatorship but on its own initiative
since it considers that it has fulfilled
the mission that brought it to yurina
culture its base of operations on the
banks of the Ucayali some 10 kilometers
from pucallpa from which it has spread
into nearly all the remote faults and
corners of Amazonia what exactly is the
purpose of the Institute according to
its enemies it is a tentacle of American
imperialism which under cover of doing
scientific research has been engaged in
gathering intelligence and has taken the
first steps toward a nail colonialist
penetration of the cultures of the
Amazonian Indians these accusations team
first and foremost from the left but
certain sectors of the Catholic Church
mainly the jungle missionaries are also
hostile to it an accused suit of being
nothing more than a valence of
Protestant evangelists passing
themselves off as linguists among the
anthropologists there are those who
criticize it for perverting the
aboriginal cultures attempting to
westernize them and roll them into a
mercantile economy a number of
conservatives disapprove of the presence
of the Institute in Peru for nationalist
and Hispanic reasons among these latter
was my professor an academic advisor
back in those days the historian porous
beret Nietzsche who when he heard that I
was going on that expedition solemnly
cautioned me be careful those Gringo's
will try to buy you he couldn't bear the
thought that because of the Institute
the jungle Indians would probably learn
to speak English before they did Spanish
friends of the Institute such as Reseda
Corp ancho defended it on crag Matic
grounds the work of the linguists study
in the languages and dialects of
Amazonia compiling lexicons and grammars
of the various tribes served the country
and besides it was supervised in theory
at least by the Ministry of Education
which had to approve of all its projects
and received copies of all the material
equal
as long as the same industry or Peruvian
universities didn't take the trouble to
pursue such research themselves it was
to produce advantage that it was being
undertaken by others
moreover the infrastructure set up by
the Institute in Amazonia with its fleet
of Hydra planes and its system of radio
communication between the headquarters
at the arena culture and the network of
linguists living with the tribes was
also of benefit to the country since
teachers civil servants and the military
forces in remote jungle localities we're
in the habit of making use of it and not
just in case of emergency the
controversy has not ended nor is it
likely to end soon that expedition of
just a few short weeks duration which I
was lucky enough to be able to join made
such a great impression on me that 27
years later I still remember it in
abundance eat a land still write about
it as I am doing now infancy we went
first to jelena culture and topped with
linguists and then a long way from there
to the region of the alto marin on visit
in a series of settlements and villages
of two tribes of the Ribeiro family the
iowa RunAs and the one business we then
went up to Lake Moroni to visit the
chakras we travel in a small hydroplane
and in some places in native canoes
along narrow river channels so topped
with tangled vegetation overhead that in
bright daylight it's him
dark as night the strength and the
solitude of nature the tall trees the
mirror smooth lagoons the immutable
rivers brought to mind a newly created
world
touched by man a paradise of plants and
animals when we reach the tribes by
contrast they are before us was
prehistory the elemental primeval
existence of our distant ancestors
hunters gatherers bald men nomads
shamans irrational and animistic these
two was Peru and only then did I become
fully aware of it a world still untamed
the Stone Age magical religious cultures
polygamy head-shrinking in ash a
prevalence of Maronna culture the
Cacique 3d explained to us through an
interpreter the complicated technique of
steeping and stuffing with herbs
required by the operation that is to say
the down of human history I am quite
sure that throughout the entire trip
I thought continually of souls aratus I
often spoke about him with his mentor
dr. mattes Mara who was also a member of
the expedition it was on this journey in
fact that we became good friends
Matis Maher told me that he had invited
soul to come with us
whether serratus has refused because he
strongly disapproved of the work of the
Institute thanks to this expedition I
was better able to understand mosquitos
fascination with this region and these
people to get some idea of the
forcefulness
of the impact that changed the course of
his life but besides that it gave me
first-hand experience that enabled me to
justify many of the differences of
opinion which more out of instinct than
out of real knowledge I had had with
soul over Amazonian cultures why did he
cling to that illusion of his wanting to
preserve these tribes
just as they were the way of life just
as it was to begin with it wasn't
possible all of them some more slowly
orders more rapidly were being
contaminated by Western and mestizo
influences moreover was this medical
preservation desirable what's going on
living the way they were the way purest
anthropologists of soul-sword wanted
them to do to the tries advantages their
primitive state made them rather victims
of the world location and cruelty